how bands can promote their remixes so a
while ago i made a video uh that
talked about banes and how to promote
your band and one of the strategies was
remix
a popular song and put into your own
style right if you if you look at
youtube any of the popular songs and you
do cover or remix
there's all these other options that
come up and if you cover a popular song
and put your own spin on it that can get
you known and then also bring a new
audience to you and i was recently
watching
uh one of my favorite youtube channels
by gary vaynerchuk
and he answered the question of how do
you then go out and promote this new
cover that you make this remix that you
make through social media
and he had such a great answer that i
thought i'd share it and hopefully you
guys can learn from his answer as well
yes
he's back yeah he's bad draga asks i'm
an indie music producer what tips do you
have to promote my content using social
media marketing
draga what's up you're back and i
respect that you're in episode one and
two you one day will be a trivia
question
so
the question is look you're an indie guy
you're trying to promote i'm actually
going to move the mic to steve he's not
even expecting this go there go there do
you have the sound
or you're good
the camera's got its own sound
go ahead say what you just said to me so
draga i looked at your twitter account
and you posted a remix of a rihanna
track eight times in the last 24 hours
since we aired the last episode of the
show actually
that's a little bit overwhelming dragon
now couple things i think the thing to
really think about is listening i was
actually clicking and so i got focused i
don't know what he was doing there but
he was replying to somebody i like the
replying in twitter that's a tactic look
here's here's what i think it's all
about the quality of the music matters
building up your soundcloud matters how
does one do that one of the ways to
really do that is to become old school
in some ways believe it or not i'm gonna
go left field on you how about some
music message boards but not spamming
them becoming a part of that community
how about
searching every single person that
tweeted about rihanna steve pull it up
every single person who tweeted about
rihanna let me guess but i'm gonna think
it's a shitload right and so in that
[ __ ] load jumping in and engaging with
those people now you gotta spend a lot
of time you decided to do a rihanna
remix not me so that means you've got to
go through it and it's gonna take you a
couple hours because everybody's gonna
be tweeting like rihanna's hot [ __ ]
rihanna all that stuff and you're gonna
have to find people that are actually
talking about rihanna's music which i
don't know probably small percentage of
what's going on on twitter you've got to
jump into that and engage with it
authentically engaging and you've heard
the 19 year old dude move is not saying
check out my track you've got to just
kind of
you know jam with people i would
recommend if you're jamming people
and jamming with people not jamming if
you're jamming with people
during that period changing the url in
your twitter profile to be a direct link
to the rihanna track that's right folks
that was a tactic and that's why
askgaryvee is going to be a big time
show if you're deciding to do something
specific for a two-day period like draga
should around engaging people around
rihanna's music that actually talk about
the music i recommend he changes his
twitter profile's url from his probably
homepage or whatever he's got going on
to the actual link to the soundcloud of
that show because while he's engaging
people can be like who the hell's draga
let me click this link in his url boom
they're listening to that the viral loop
gets going the viral loop gets going
justin asks where are the best places
for hiring great employees these days
what's your process
uh the best places to hire great
employees is actually this is kind of
like the honey and bees thing my process
is a little bit different i'm actively
running a social and digital agency and
i am at the
lucky stage of my career where i'm a
known personality in that and i'm public
speaking i'm doing the askgaryvee show
plug and
you know it's coming to us right i'm at
that place now so that's not practical
for the far majority of people watching
this and because i want this to be
practical
i would say what i would think is very
simply the best tactic for all of you
watching who want to hire good people is
to search the key terms on twitter
search that are talking about the things
that you do for a living and then doing
the homework the dirty little secret is
my friends is most people don't want to
work you know how easy it is to find
good employees let me explain you go to
twitter search you search the terms
around the job description that you want
not the job description terms but the
kind of things they'd be doing
looking at people talking about design
websites design forums design aspects
and then looking around what people are
saying then clicking on their profile
clicking their homepage probably landing
on their design portfolio finding four
people that you think do a good job
emailing them or tweeting at them saying
do you want to interview for a job are
you looking for a job three of them for
say no one says yes the other three give
you four referrals that are kind of like
them you've got five people interview
and you hire one of those people but
that just took eight hours didn't it
and that my friends is how you actually
do it because everybody's looking for
quick tactics to make it easy and
putting in the work
always
always
matters
you